[Music]
nicki's in ohio
nikki what's up hi dave i i love your
show and i appreciate you taking my call
a little bit nervous too because it's
such a long story and i'm going to try
and shorten things up
okay um my parents both passed away last
year in 2019 my dad in june
and my mom in december and
my dad was in the nursing home for a
little while while he was in the nursing
home my mom
decided she was going to show me all of
her hiding places of
cash in the house that they had stashed
for years
so luckily i took pictures of all the
hiding places and
lo and behold then my mom passed in
december and
everyone told me well nicki if there's
any cash in the house make sure you get
that out of there now
got it out in two grocery bags and
it took me about three weeks and finally
one night i decided for a glass of wine
put my bluetooth speaker in the bedroom
and i started
counting and there was a hundred and
sixty one thousand dollars
i'm glad you're laughing about this i
will tell you it caused me the most
anxiety for the longest time and
i finally called called my financial
advisor
and he said nikki this is a happy
problem to have yeah this is a two glass
of wine problem
not one glass exactly i'm thinking
bottle here
161 thousand dollars in coffee cans
some tom farron yeah wow you can't
even imagine where she has this cash hit
i do believe i got a call out of there
and um
so i i contacted my financial advisor
and like i say it's always a happy
problem he said if there's any home
improvements you need to do
to make your house you know value up a
little bit
do that and so i did like a kitchen
refresh i probably have a good
and a couple other things i probably
have a good 125 cash of that 125 000
left of that and then i also sold their
home
um in which i took that money
and i paid off my health i i became i'm
on baby step four without like i went
zero to four
you've done wonderful wonderful okay how
how can i help i don't know what the
problem is well i
okay gosh started i don't know what to
do with this cash
investment it's not it's not drug money
it's not illegal invest it
okay it's not cocaine money
[Laughter]
you're making me feel a little better
well you didn't do anything wrong she
didn't do anything wrong
yeah take a vacation invest the rest
it's a it's a little bit
of a movie that needs to be written or a
book but
but i get that it's you know it kind of
it makes your head go on tilt but you
know you've got a pile of cash in the
kitchen table and it's not even
proverbial it's real
and so um yeah you're out of debt and
you're on baby step seven
aren't you you paid off your house all
right well yes i guess i am off seven
yes
okay so now you're just investing for
you know and you know so you here's
three things you do with excess money
you invest it
you give with outrageous generosity and
you enjoy it
and you should do some of each with this
money you should go on a crude now
they're going to do cruises
now you should have some fun with the
money and
you should give some of the money hire
an investigator i'd double check that
house
i feel like there's more in the world
scanning thing
thermal scanning yeah